hablamos de economía en France 24 por
ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
bienvenido hoy vamos a iniciar hablando
de la cerveza las razones que distintos
economistas aseguran que esta bebida
alcohólica es a prueba de recesiones y
que en escenarios económicos complejos
pues las grandes empresas todavía Pueden
seguir obteniendo ganancias como es esto
Así es el panorama que vamos a revisar
hoy Pues mira algunos expertos como
usted lo decía concuerdan que cuando la
inflación golpea a un país lo que
normalmente se espera es que las
personas supriman de su consumo normal
las bebidas alcohólicas incluidas las
cervezas que van de la mano pues ya
usted pensará con las salidas y las
fiestas todo una industria de
esparcimiento y recreación otros por el
contrario creen que independientemente
de la situación económica los
consumidores no abandonan la cerveza y
en cambio generan buenas ganancias para
la industria en tiempos de crisis
nosotros hablamos expertos del sector
Pues estamos hablando de Miguel Rivas
quienes pues es narrador de historias de
la industria cervecera él los explicó la
relación que existe entre la inflación y
la cerveza y las empresas y además los
consumidores
Mira me parece que
es una herramienta como muchas otras
pero bueno ahorita estamos hablando de
cerveza es una herramienta para Sí para
medir un poco más que la recepción es
más como un termómetro también para
medir
el nivel o cómo está la economía el
bolsillo de de la persona de a pie
y la manera que se puede ver eso o sea
cuando uno está teniendo que tiene que
recortar gastos pues uno de las primeras
cosas que uno tiene que hacer es sacar
las cosas que no tienen prioridad por lo
general están eso en la salida de ir a
comer a restaurante viajar tomar
entonces pues sí podría decirse que que
la cerveza puede servir como como un
barómetro no para para medir
Cómo está la situación económica
Juan Pablo Cuáles son los argumentos de
los expertos que consideran que la
cerveza sí esquiva la recesión pues
miremos exactamente el otro lado porque
estudios han revelado que las compañías
cerveceras han hecho pues lo que esté a
su alcance para no verse afectadas por
ejemplo poner estos productos en oferta
a un nivel más asequible aunque esto
represente menos ganancias esto en un
panorama de crisis nos centraremos por
ejemplo en Estados Unidos allí una
encuesta de 2021 de gala que es una
empresa de análisis y asesoría con sede
en Washington señala que el ciudadano
estadounidense promedio consume 3,6
bebidas alcohólicas por semana y el 60%
de los encuestados dice que consumen
cualquier tipo de alcohol en general
según los estudios esa especie de
inmunidad ante la recesión es más
notable en cervezas Premium que rara vez
son defraudadas por su base de
consumidores estamos hablando estas
cervezas artesanales que tienen una
carga simbólica muchas veces para las
personas otros lo que hacen es que no
dejan de consumir cerveza pero tratan de
buscar la opción más económica sin
embargo luego de la pandemia Pues
también presentaron problemas para estas
empresas la virtualización masiva de las
compras y como muchos de sus ventas
dependían de la venta en tiendas sus
ganancias cayeron significativamente
justo aquí es donde entra la pregunta
qué soluciones han tenido las empresas Y
cómo pueden lidiar con la mente del
consumidor a la hora de realizar su
compra esto nos dijo el invitado Mira
hay algo también que hay que tener en
cuenta es que de la misma manera que
sube el precio
de la cerveza para el consumidor también
les están subiendo el precio de los
ingredientes de producción a la
cerveceras a las industriales y a las
artesanales entonces de la misma manera
que la inflación le afecta al consumidor
también le está afectando a los
productores y no solamente los
productores también está afectando a los
productores de los también de los
ingredientes entonces es una cadena que
no solamente afecta al consumidor final
que sí Bueno eso a la final lo que
nosotros no como consumidores no es lo
que nos afecta uno no está pensando
Bueno sí al granjero le subió
el precio del abono Entonces ellos
tienen que subir el precio también de de
la cebada uno no está pensando en eso no
es verdad uno
no es escenarios afectan las ventas de
las grandes marcas cerveceras
precisamente Valentina revisemos este
escenario con las cifras porque las
ventas totales de cerveza en Estados
Unidos crecieron un 1,8% interanual en
las 12 12 semanas que finalizaron el 20
de mayo según datos de las firmas de
investigación nielsenique y Tv cowen
pero justo en ese mismo mes la cerveza
más vendida de Estados Unidos estamos
hablando de Bud Light perdió el primer
puesto que llevaba ocupando por más de
20 años desbancada por la mexicana
modelo especial pues esto al menos en
ese mes en mayo modelo acaparo el 8,4%
de las ventas minoristas en este periodo
mientras que Bot light cayó al segundo
lugar con el
7,3%, las ventas en dólares fueron
Igualmente sombrías para Bud Light
durante ese periodo con una caída del
24,4% mientras que las de modelo
crecieron un 12,2% Bueno pero entonces
han hecho las cerveceras con sus precios
para contrarrestar este panorama
Valentina vamos a llevar esto a los
precios precisamente porque muchas de
ellas han escogido Pues cuando hay
momentos de precios elevados de
inflación cambiar un poco los precios en
ese panorama y lo revisaremos en el
siguiente gráfico porque por ejemplo
tenemos a natural light que pues ellos
que es una marca de Kingston tiene y es
una es una cerveza de ligera que tiene
un precio de 4,99 dólares estamos
hablando de 16 onzas usted puede ver que
por ejemplo la que le sigue tiene 7,40
dólares esta también es una ligera
Premium es de Bot light que pues lo que
decíamos ahora perdió el primer puesto y
otras que son un poco más costosas que
están entre los 10 y 12 dólares y ahí
vamos a poder ver también las ganancias
de estas empresas porque es una opción
diferente que le dan a los consumidores
y bueno también podemos decir que es un
mercado un poco reducido los que se
mantienen en sus cervezas su cerveza
favorita que no van a cambiar la marca a
pesar de los precios altos así es y era
como decía nuestro invitado precisamente
porque tienen una conexión con la marca
con estas cervezas Premium muchas de
ellas tienen una historia detrás en su
creación en su producción entonces dejan
el cono dejan el consumo los
consumidores pues Juan Pablo usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación en
este tema muy interesante para muchas
personas en el mundo a ustedes gracias
por su sintonía quédense con nosotros
que hay más en France 24